welcome everyone to dc thursday
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council
and the data community fund and i am
excited to be your guide
through the crazy sprawling data data
ecosystem
uh today we have another amazing guest
who
i'm excited to to welcome tom banz
is the co-founder of soda data
where he's also the cto and
prior to that tom was a repeat founder
she founded a company called rockscript
as well as a company called effective
prior to that he was a distinguished
engineer at scenavio
a chief architect at alfresco and before
that he was the jppm product lead at
jboss
and red hat after the jboss acquisition
so tom welcome to the show yeah thanks a
lot
it's great to be here a fan of dc
thursday so it's a
it's great for me to be here well it's
great it's great to have you
um and you've had such a deep uh an
early little illustrious career in open
source
i'm curious to hear about the the
earliest stages
jboss is something i haven't thought
about or heard mentioned
in a long time and that was obviously an
early part of the
the open source revolution so i'm
curious maybe you can start to tell us a
little bit about
that end of your career um and we can
work backwards
yeah yeah definitely so yeah jaboz
brings back memories that's for me how
all things get started um yeah so
essentially before
jboss i was uh working with a dreadful
workflow engine
and i started to build my own flavor as
a hobby project
but after a while i realized that my
hobby project would be a great addition
for jboss
so i wrote like a cold email to mark
fleury saying
like what a great engineer i had and how
well it would be to
to add it to journal and he was probably
very busy and
answered something along the lines of go
and play somewhere else right
but but i kept pushing and so even
i took a paid training course to
to just be able to show my engine
i didn't want to go to the training
course just wanted to show the engine
right
and then a few months later jboss
acquired my jbpm project so
uh it ended pretty nice and that's where
things got started from me uh
getting in in context in contact with
the
open source world interesting and what
was open source like at the time
um was it something that was well
understood do you feel like
what about the engineering community
like what was it like to go work
as an engineer at an open source company
did that raise any eyebrows
uh yeah there was like the the linux
uh ecosystem was there and it was like
totally different and this was the first
time when
really like companies were being born
that were actually making money
with open source and having that as a
strategy
and that somehow uh yeah that raised
some eyebrows left and right but i think
uh
in a nutshell i think my position to
that has always been very positive i
think
open source always leaves a trail
basically of software that people can
use and beyond the people that pay for
it you have a large community that can
just
use it and benefit from it so that's
always a win
and so then you ended up at red hat
through the jboss acquisition
um red hat obviously was one of the only
multi-billion dollar companies probably
the only multi-billion dollar company in
open source
um which paved the way for many more but
um these were the early days what what
was that like
so in for me that we still operated
pretty much
independent as long as i was there so i
didn't really have like a
a red hat like totally integrated but i
totally
am with you in the fact that it's a bit
mixed uh for me on the one hand i think
it's great that
red hat does so well but on the other
hand i would
like to see more of those very large
companies uh based on open source
actually
i think in that sense um yeah that would
be great that in the future
there's like a lot more open source
adoption we see nowadays
but real companies building like
multi-billion dollar companies are open
that's that would be nice
well from there you went to um
alfresco which was also a good success
story
um rising up open source content
management as i recall
how did you end up at alfresco yeah so
basically there was a license conflict
and also i realized we needed to go
apache
license which is a more liberal open
source license it allows
more uh and there was like a reason uh
why we wanted to go that way
that's how i ended up at alfresco so i
could build like actually
the quite similar thing is what i did
earlier
and that was a community open source
community called activity
also an open source workflow engine in
the java ecosystem for engineers by
engineers
and that uh was like quite a different
experience in the sense like
it was much more widely adopted
and um yeah so widely adopted
and multiple companies uh built on it so
not the same as with jboss here there
was like more
forks so more yeah other companies
actually
making money of the same project as well
as companies
using it companies just using it
internally or to add it to their product
and this is of this is alfresco you're
talking about yes that was the activity
project
inside i see inside of
alfresco back at the time activity was
like
an embedded workflow engine that added
some features but i think from my
perspective activity was
was even bigger uh beyond the scope of
how it was used inside of alfresco
so there's this running theme of
workflow engines
um in your in your past um
what's the big deal with workflow
engines like why why did you end up sort
of getting into that
that field it's a it's a good question
uh
so yeah no i think um it's just
something i
started doing i like doing and i don't
consider myself like a
super rock star programmer but what i
did was i just
implemented the workflow engines like a
gazillion times over and over again
until you know every design decision
inside out
so and i don't know why but it just like
uh kept motivating me it kept
kept being uh inspirational
interesting and and that continued on
because then you started yet another
workflow company if i'm not mistaken
is that effective correct effective at
synovial
was a totally different uh type thing
because here it was like the first real
enterprise
sas company that i found it the mission
there was to make workflows simpler
and uh yeah so we built like a ui
on how people without any skills like it
was a no
code environment that we created a
product
where people could build their own
workflows and
yeah as part of a business process
management uh
suite at synavio basically so yeah still
proud of that product
very much and so recently i just learned
that cyanavio just got bought by sap so
that
is now part of that
company yeah that's that that's a that
was a great win and a great success for
scenavio for sure
um you met you mentioned no code i'm
curious
um what are your thoughts on the no code
movement
overall is that something that you've um
spent a bunch of time thinking about or
how does that affect
your personal views yeah yeah definitely
that
that like i like working in
that realm of building frameworks for
people
that translate between what users want
to do then
create a platform in between that makes
it easier to translate into some running
system
so typically if you run code
then you're very flexible but you have
the technical complexities of writing
code
and um so yeah i don't know why but like
say as an engineer i
like to build these frameworks that make
it a little bit easier to implement all
of these things
so that you have to code less create
like what's called back in the days like
a dsl a domain specific
language which is now often done in yaml
files for instance
um so that that kind of uh
yeah that drives me a lot that kind of
[Music]
products you got it and so in general
like what what would you say the
less the big biggest lessons where you
learned um
surrounding open source and open source
companies
at that point in your career yeah yeah
open source for me personally is very
rewarding so
i like to make people happy and so on
forums
open source users they give a lot of
kudos
uh they show that they're happy with
what you're built and then they ask for
the next feature and that's really
motivating so
so that keeps me always going uh but
even
if i never talk to them just knowing
that loads of people
all around the world use your software
is i think a great feeling
yeah for sure well then so where does
data fit in how did you
end up moving into data i'm curious um
yeah so i went into data after
uh the last project i was like okay
what's happening in the
space i yeah i didn't want to start yet
another
workflow engine and then i realized like
oh all the exciting stuff
is happening in the data space these
days so
that's when i decided to go into that
direction and it's not
i didn't consider it as one of the
software hypes i really think that
the data transformation happening now is
like the next
big transformation in software so that's
why
i wanted to go into that direction and
after a while i met
martin and his ideas in data quality
have great overlap with the things that
i was doing in workflow engines
i was mainly like the collaboration and
the low code solutions
so that fitted really really well with
that
and and how did you meet martin i'm
always curious to hear stories of how
co-founders met each other because
sometimes it
you know well there's there's so many
different stories and angles on how this
happens how did it work for you
yeah that's that's a nice story as well
i think uh
so martin time was working at calibra
and they
were using activity the engine we just
spoke about so that was part of their
product
and martin and his colleague they were
on the train to london
and his colleague spotted me and
recognized me as the workflow guy in the
train so
i was just on my way to work because uh
alfresco was based in london
and so they came over for a chat uh and
that's
uh yeah the first time we met so it was
actually in a train
going 200 kilometers an hour 70 meters
under the sea
on sounds like a very european story
yeah yeah definitely um and
what would you say like how did you
decide that
um ultimately you wanted to work
together with martin
like what what are the most important
things for you
as an engineer cto when thinking about
picking a co-founder
yep yeah i think the the most by far the
most important and i think it's a
classic
is just make sure that you're
complementary and i think that works
really well
i could experience like what that means
if you're complementary and if you have
less overlap that also helps to
establish
trust because it's more like oh you
don't have different opinions on the
same topic because you know that
if your co-founder is doing the business
side of things and he has an opinion on
that then okay then
there's more trust to leave it to the
other side the same for the technical
aspects
and so trust is actually then the other
factor so we took our
time we spent more than a half a year
before
actually making the plunge and getting
started to make sure that the trust was
really established and that
that was a solid basis
got it so so you didn't start you didn't
immediately start talking about the
company
um uh on the train during the train
meeting ah no true that was actually
yeah our first meeting was on the train
and then only late that
we ah yeah actually now that you bring
it up that was later that there was this
post uh martin wanted to find a
co-founder he had the original idea
he said like let's find his co-founder
so he plugged
a number of posts on data forms
and that's where i was getting into data
so i picked one of those
picked up one of those messages and
that's when after 15 minutes of
phone conversation you immediately know
like this is the next
for me yeah that was a quick decision
and an easy one at that time
that's great so so that this this is the
origin story of soda
um formerly called soda data now i think
you dropped the data for some reason and
now you're just soda
um any particular reason uh no i think
we
yeah i think it's just shorter and i
think after we dropped it after we
knew that the all trademark things were
handled properly so
okay okay got short and sweet to the
point yeah
and and so so what's the key insight
that soda
is built on i find that um when two
founders get together and have some view
of
a product they need to build um they're
usually empowered by some
some key thing that drives them um some
way they see the world
what what is that for soda yeah yeah so
i think there's a couple of things but
the first and primary thing is that
data issues they are inevitable so let
me
zoom in here for a second so consider
the data product
as any piece of software that's using
data and that continuously
is being refreshed like that's a data
product think of a recommendation
algorithm
price calculations of taxi rides or
hotel rooms all based on data like
that's a data product
the data that goes in there comes from
complex i.t infrastructures and data
pipelines all stitched together
sometimes in brittle ways
so it's actually impossible to prevent
to take a strategy to try and prevent
data issues
so this infrastructure is so complex so
many people involved
your data will break that's the first
observation
and if it's not detected the software
the data products the software that will
continue to work
so your results will be off which means
your the prices of your hotel rooms will
be of
your taxi rides or your recommendations
which are quite important for revenue
those will be off and so that's why it's
very important
and so the only option that you're left
with is to make sure
that you monitor closely and that you
catch these
issues proactively and that you deal
with the issues as they pop up
rather than trying to prevent them so
that's the first uh part of it
the second observation that soda is
based on is that companies
rely a lot more on data so
just as i said these price
recommendations
so amazon for instance they make 35
of their revenue through the
recommendations uh and
i mentioned the price algorithms as well
so companies rely a lot more so it's
becoming a lot more important than
before to actually do those monitorings
and then on the data team
side teams are getting bigger and that
makes it
easier harder to coordinate between
all the people involved often there's
like data silos
or different teams for different types
of data
and there's also the technical side
versus the people with the business
knowledge
so all of these people need to get
involved to
to actually make data monitored and then
help to resolve
the issues there so those are the the
key three uh
yeah insights that soda is based on
and and how are these insights derived
from
from the founders experience would you
say because you both come from
many years of experience in enterprise
software i'm curious if there's any
examples you know personal examples that
you can point to that
um prove to you the importance of this
yeah
so yeah not that long ago
[Music]
companies started to organize around the
data colibra was right at the forefront
of when that happened and so martin was
involved
in a variety of implementations of
data governance projects at calibra and
yeah his background basically is got a
lot of knowledge
on how these data teams work who does
what what the typical problems are
and how they're dealing with these data
issues so um
yeah and he spotted them a long time ago
that data quality
was going to become like a major
bottleneck in
data adoption and data data stacks going
forward
yeah so fruit yeah um for the
from the start basically both of us
uh want a bottom-up strategy
so because we believe that there's like
a huge opportunity
for mass adoption in this space with a
through an open source track so that's
also something that we're both
definitely uh connected
always passionate as mentioned before on
low code and no code
and yeah that background on the
workflows that helped me
build the product and i think in terms
of data
it's nice i think what i can bring there
is shifting between shifting gears
basically between
on the one hand having the full
flexibility of
dealing with this in a coding style for
engineers
then also having the configuration
option like the low
code is like configurations for the
analytics engineer
and then going all the way up to a ui
for self-service monitoring creation
and let's say making sure i think that's
from my background it's like
making the trade-offs between
flexibility and coding
and then a ui to to automate these
things that's
something that i've done a couple of
times before so that's
uh that's what i get good table
yeah so i guess in that way um there's
this sort of overlap between
i mean perhaps you're trying to bring
some sort of a workflow
understanding um into the data sphere
um so i guess based on that what what is
the
what does this sort of product do
exactly yeah so
and in essence soda establishes
trust in your data products that's
that's the main goal right
it does this by continuously monitoring
for those issues and
catching them and then driving the
resolution process
so the the business process that you
have to to make sure that you
uh have a smooth and fast resolution
process
and so in order to build up a picture of
what good data looks like
soda combines three different inputs
machine learning is one of them so that
learns
what normal data is by just looking at
the data
and that's great to enable monitoring on
a complete warehouse or a complete
complete data lake without having the
capacity or the knowledge to specify
all of these details manually right
that's where
machine learning comes in to start
having a base layer of monitoring
fully automated then a second level
is the analysts and the subject meta
experts they augment this
with their domain knowledge so for them
we make it easier
to do like cell service monitorings with
a simple ui based in in three different
steps basically they can create their
own monitors
that way using their domain knowledge
and adding that
to the the list of like what does good
data look like
and then the third category or third
input is the data engineers
they and the analytics engineers as well
as they're building their
data transformations they have a good
idea technically
what the requirements are and that they
need to test from a technical
perspective
these are the data tests basically and
that's just like unit tests and software
so those are the three types of input
like that we have that we use in soda as
to define what good data looks like
once we know that we can do the
continuous monitoring each time new data
arrives then we check it
and we can generate alerts right and
then there's the whole
resolution process that we support in
terms of diagnosing
triaging priority prior
priorities to say no prioritizing yeah
that's it
[Music]
and then the resolving of the issues so
as the head of data you can think of
soda as the business process in a box
to drive this process um
so we drive the complete process of
specifying what good data looks like and
then
catching issues and driving the whole
resolution process
and so the three the three ways that you
um
sort of construct what good data looks
like again is by machine learning
via subject matter experts who have the
capacity to sort of
use the tool to define a certain data
pattern
or say a certain data quality factor
or metric and then also you said there's
a
the engineers how do the engineers sort
of work in this loop i want to ask you
about the machine learning as well but
we can talk about that next um
first first how do the engineers
interact in the system
yeah so the engineers they like to work
with
configuration files like yaml files they
want
that to fit into their workflow which is
like it should
be integrated into their git repository
so they have their source code of their
transformation they want the tests
to be in that same git repository needs
to be version controlled
and deployed together with all the rest
of their software in their
transformation so i think for them that
is really key
and so um yeah that's uh
that's there got it um
and what about the machine learning bits
like how does that piece work is that
fully unsupervised
machine learning yes so that's
essentially like as you connect
initially your warehouse we're gonna
just scan
everything and of course we cannot scan
in-depth because then we're just
overloading the whole warehouse
so we're gonna start by uh specifying
like
monitoring some key aspects of your data
set like when does it arrive
like the row counts the volumes and a
couple of other key metrics
and that's where we applied an anomaly
detection algorithms to just
keep an eye on those core metrics so
that
initially you get to see like these are
the data sets that are maybe like stable
instable if data for a long time arrives
very
regularly at 8 00
a.m in the morning and then it certainly
doesn't that's when we can generate
already an alarm
and we can create awareness around these
process
these problems using ml and so the the
main thing there is that
you don't typically have the capacity as
a this is for the data platform team
right they don't have the capacity they
don't have the knowledge of
all the transformation pipelines of all
the data in there
but they are supplying an infrastructure
piece in the data platform
to say to to let everyone else
deal with or monitor the data so um
yeah that's essentially the the
background of of that story there
and how would you say that teams did
this previously
uh teams previously they were blocked
usually or entered into a bottleneck
because
the business people they had certain
monitors certain
checks that they want to do and then
they had to go to the engineering team
to actually get that implemented and
that process is typically so slow
so that none of the domain knowledge
gets implemented
there's no automation so you basically
don't
uh monitor this essentially i think
that's
that's in a nutshell the situation i
think it's also
not that long that we're experiencing
the problem
because the the volume of data that's
being used is growing so rapidly right
so the problem is now
getting a lot bigger and as i said now
companies rely a lot more so it becomes
more crucial that the data is accurate
i think in the past it was just not done
at this scale and with this decision
and and for a data to adopt a data
quality solution in general
do you think that what like what's the
threshold
for team size for data volume size like
at what point should teams start to
consider
looking into a more automated data
quality solution
that's a great point so there and it
depends on
your role right so we've constructed our
solutions so that every individual role
can start
adopting uh it for their specific needs
so we
have an open source project uh or a
series of them
that allows the engineers to
for their own pipeline make their own
decision to adopt
this library this tool to do data
testing
so they can already get going with this
and the same like
a data platform team can actually decide
to enable
a data monitoring so that data
monitoring on their platform right
so and then the let's say it's the head
of the
data or the cdo's those can make like an
initiative to say oh what
what do we need from a whole company
perspective in terms of strategy
and that's those are the three angles
that we see
that we want to tackle like both from an
individual personal perspective
we need to make sure we provide value to
those individual roles
as well as to the overall perspective
like if you're only doing
engineering data testing then you don't
have a full coverage of
all the things that you want to monitor
on your data so you also need the
analytics engineer and the subject
method
experts to be involved otherwise your
picture of what good data looks like is
not complete right
and where we're in the data pipeline is
the
ideal point of insertion would you say
for for data monitoring tools is this
i mean i i guess it's obviously it's pre
warehouse but
but how far are pre-warehouse and is
there a situation where
you can be capturing anomalies um you
know that that are sort of on their way
into the warehouse
but you're still several steps removed
from those anomalies um
like or were originally created like
what what's the
sort of fidelity there in terms of how
and where and how often
you should be testing data across your
pipeline that's a
it's a great question and actually i
think now i realize it's the same thing
as with unit testing you shouldn't
unit test one part of your code more
than other parts so
also in data all of the pipelines are
needed to be tested what we see in
practice however
is that as closer you get to the data
products
that's where it's easier to do the
testing that's where the data is
more prepared and it's also that's the
last place where you can
really capture all of the issues because
if some issue happens far
they're upstream then you can still
catch it at the end as well
but then so typically the approach we
see is that people start close to the
data products
uh in the refined data and then work
their way upstream
um so yeah and then the data engineers
on themselves
we see them as well taking some of that
responsibility
and just start building in these checks
into their pipelines with data testing
tools
and is this uh is it typically a pre-dbt
thing or a post-dbt thing if a company
is doing a lot of transforms yeah i
think
i think that's one of those
transformations where it makes sense in
my opinion to do it both
before and after dbt already implies
sql accessible data which is sometimes
even let's say in the
later stages but that makes perfect
sense to do it before
and after but it's in that space that
where it's
typically uh very relevant definitely
got it and what would you say about the
the nature of the modern data
infrastructure stack like why
why is the time now you already
mentioned obviously
um the complexity of data is increasing
the volume of data is increasing and
dependency
on data is is increasing um are there
any other macro
trends sort of an infrastructure that um
have really caused you to double down on
this from the from a sort of perspective
yeah yeah so yeah there's a couple of
high level trends that we
we saw playing into this of course as i
mentioned a couple of times before like
more data is being around then there's
also the responsibility for data
shifted over the last years more from
i.t
to the business and so business takes
more ownership and there's more business
people involved
in actually making sure that data
is uh in very fit condition um
so and then there's also the data
technology landscape that
that's another trend that changed right
we went from all up over to data lakes
and now there's like
towards sql so that's uh
that also has a profound impact
on all of the solutions in this space
and why
actually i we think that it's not really
like a market category that's being
created
from scratch but it is told because of
these reasons it's totally
uh redefined actually so the solutions
from the past totally don't work anymore
you mentioned um you mentioned maybe if
i understood you
the world's sort of moving back to sql
um is that your
is that your um your sense yeah
definitely that's actually our promotion
marketing message behind one of our
projects so we have
full coverage with our connectors
connectivity over the full landscape so
we do sql
as well as streaming as well as spark
and data lakes
but the message for sequel soda sql
itself that's where we say like
go all in uh without shame like back to
the sequel right
yeah i think it's actually a nice story
because i think it's a misconception
so we we went from uh
olap over to data lakes and then to sql
at some point there was like this no
sequel thing
and i think it was a mistake because i
should actually have called it maybe
something like no transactions because
sql is actually still
very valuable and we go all the way back
to that because we
regain there's like more awareness now
that the
sql is actually the good thing and i
think it's transactions that
have been lost along the way some
no no asset i don't know no transactions
exactly i i like that no transactions
that that's uh well said i mean
that that really captures actually i
think more the core of
what we were trying to accomplish with i
mean there was also the the
denormalization of data
and um sort of some other fancy things
but you are right that
um you know the the transactional
component of these data stores was the
first thing
to go when we started to munch around
with different kinds of
column restores and other data layouts
right
yeah yeah definitely
um so so you've mentioned
a bunch um you know in your in your
comments about
um different types of people across
the data organization different players
um
like can can you can can we like drill
into that a little bit more i'm curious
to hear your
thoughts on what you feel are
modern patterns of collaboration
across different types of data teams in
the enterprise and how those are
evolving and changing yeah okay
yeah let me give you a step so um
we have the uh yeah i think some of them
we mentioned before
like the data platform engineers right
those
um are the ones that supply the
infrastructure towards the organization
towards the data organization
all the teams building data products and
they're responsible for the
infrastructure so as part of their data
platform
they want to enable data quality
monitoring service
and enable it to everyone so they don't
have a complete insight into
every different pipeline every different
data set itself
not uh not in that and then there's like
the
data engineers and the data analytics or
the analytics engineers they're building
transformations
and they often do them data testing uh
before off and after those
transformations
and actually i think it's a should be a
pattern to
build those data tests as you build the
building the transformations because as
you're building those transformations
that's when these engineers have the
full context
of what the preconditions are what are
their assumptions that they make in that
specific trend
transition or transformation and then
they also know
what kind of simple checks at the end of
that transformation make sense to just
see if everything went okay
so if you're if you're doing a certain
join in your data transformation and it
makes sense to
okay how can i do a quick check
afterwards so that this
still um still is valid so
you have that context as you're building
it that's the moment you should
capture knowledge and data tests because
going back afterwards is going to be uh
yeah super clumsy and then yeah the
third is of course the
analysts and the subject meta experts
right so they have a lot of domain
knowledge that we want to include
these are things like on a sunday in
france you shouldn't give more than
three percent discount
those kind of very business like
knowledge uh domain knowledge is
actually crucial to be captured
and there we remove actually the
the round trip with the engineers right
so that it scales
if you don't if you need a round trip
with engineers then
you can't capture all of this domain
knowledge in your monitoring solution
and and is the subject matter expert is
that the same person as the
ultimate consumer of the data or are
there variations there
the subject matter experts typically
give them to someone that for instance
knows the data of a sales force inside
out
that is responsible to to just keep the
the system up and running and is
involved with the business processes
from the business angle
but also has a responsibility in terms
of making sure that the data is correct
so that's a new responsibility that
they're being given in top
off uh managing that system
and so so i get it so so they might not
be the end consumer of the data but
they're responsible
sort of for the all the business
understanding
um you know that that goes into the
context behind that data so so then what
happens when
somebody further downstream the actual
consumer
of the data finds an error how does that
person collaborate back with the rest of
this team what what what do you think
that loop looks like
yeah i think at the moment there is not
really like a go-to
uh place so that's where we provide a
solution as our monitoring
kicks in we start bringing all these
different
information together of what is good
data look like
then when we spot something and when we
measure
the data that's also when we capture a
lot of diagnostics information as well
um as to like what was going wrong what
were the expectations and what was
actually
um what we measured and how it
invalidated
the check basically and that's something
that we bring then into the
into the mix at that point so if someone
notices like this is way off
we notice this then everyone can come
together on the platform
and start diagnosing like what has
happened
and so typical things and that's also
where
data monitoring is actually quite
different from infrastructure monitoring
infrastructure is like
you want your cpu level to be monitored
in a simple chart right
but then for data that's not sufficient
to actually start just
monitoring this if you say like oh um
for this column the values are only
valid if they're within this list
right then you not only want to see like
i have
500 uh invalid values though you want to
see the full context of the rows for
all those things that have invalid
values because you want to know like in
which
which country was that for which client
was that that's the kind of analysis you
need to do in the diagnostics process
and so that yeah that's uh maybe a
diversion but that's uh
that's quite nice yeah that makes
perfect sense
um well speaking a little bit more
broadly
i'm curious to hear your thoughts
because you've spent so much time
looking at the sector
how do you think the data ecosystem is
going to change in the next five years
like what what should we be looking out
for
ah okay yeah i think that uh definitely
probably in an open door like sql is
gonna
keep gaining uh momentum i think we're
not full
like we're pretty far in the sense that
we can see that this is
this is really going uh yeah going to
become big again but that will continue
to grow and then the second
very important is streaming so the
landscape
currently is rather fragmented in
streaming so which makes adoption harder
but i expect there that the tools will
evolve more to similar concepts and that
it will become easier to build streaming
applications because the tools will
start to
look more alike and then the patterns on
how to employ streaming in your
architecture
both on your operational systems as well
as in your data transformations
i think that's going to be easier and
that's when it gets more broadly adopted
if you look
over the course of the next five years
well the the streaming is is relatively
complicated
and um there's a lot of ground to be
claimed there in terms of
making systems that are easier to use
easier to understand
um and you know basically being able to
be set up and
and configured and managed by um a team
that's not an elite
uh data engineering team so i think
there's a lot of
um a lot of room uh to make streaming
solutions simpler and
i'm excited to to see companies popping
up from
data council in the data council network
that are focused on that as well
yep definitely makes sense um
so tom where can people get in touch
with you if they want to ask you more
questions about
data monitoring where can they try out
soda how can they get in touch with you
um you know drop us a couple things so
that folks know where they can reach out
yep so i think the in terms of pointers
i'll make it easy just go to soda dot io
i think that's good for for this medium
just stick at that
and look out for both like soda sql i
think it's definitely
something to mention you can start
playing around with the open source
project so the sql
um and then uh also there is like a
connection with the soda cloud
that's in terms of our products
definitely worth to check that out
and also if you want to learn more
there's like a sort of live event as
well that you can find on our website
uh that's also a good place where you
can
dive in a bit deeper so okay great
that sounds like helpful resources um so
tom
before i let you go i just wanted to ask
you a last question
um i'm curious what surprised you about
your work in the data ecosystem so far
that's a good question so i think i i
think my biggest surprise if i
think about it is that data testing that
that's only now becoming a thing in the
data space so
coming from the software engineering
side it's like a given you don't write
software without
tests you might discuss in terms of the
depth of testing or when you want to
reach like 100 or not
but everyone is testing and so that was
my biggest surprise it's like
okay it's not a given data space yet and
i think it's going to come
so yeah i think that's well said and
there's a lot of
patterns and principles of traditional
software engineering that we've
learned and and have evolved over the
last 20 or 30 years
um that we're just starting now to start
to enforce in the in the data world
um and so i think um you know having a
clear sense of of some of those
principles
and um finding the white space in data
where
they need to be applied is a is a it's a
great mental
model and um i i i'm excited to see how
you're pushing that forward
on the soda side yep well well thanks
for joining us tom it was great to have
you here
it was a pleasure all on my side
thanks a lot and thanks to the rest of
the community for tuning in
for another dc thursday we have many
many more sessions coming up this year
with amazing guests so we hope you'll
continue to join us and tune in
our next event on may 13th will be with
the data coral founder
and ceo raghu murthy and we'll be
talking about
change data capture so don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
hit the bell icon to get notifications
when we go live next
and remember that you can find all the
previous dc thursday
episodes on our youtube playlist so
thanks again for